I want to revisit just,
just for a moment, uh,
the opening of the invocation
to holy light, uh, which
is of course, as you know,
is it the beginning of book
three of paradise lost.
So this is page two 57 of the Hughes
and this is how Milton begins the
vocation as you remember, hail,
holy light offspring of heaven,
first born or of the
eternal coeternal being.
May I express the and blamed,
and you'll remember the last week we,
uh,
we looked at Milton's desire to imagine
himself on blamed or in some way,
unbelievable for the condition of his
blindness Milton had for Milton had for
years gone out of his way to justify
himself before his nation and before his
God.
But that,
that was only one way to read this line.
May I ask this question?
May I express the on blamed and blamed
can just as easily modify it seems to me
it can just as easily modify the holy
light being addressed by the poet.
It can correspond to the D as
well as the eye in that question.
And so it's this alternative syntactical
possibility that I want to explore in
this lecture.
Uh,
well I'll be focusing on the status of
this poem as an attempt to exculpate not
only this poet, but, but this poets,
this poet's God to render God blameless
for the range of losses that this epic
so eloquently.
Enumerates.
So a look at the sentence that
I've written on the board from,
from doctor Johnson's life of Milton.
His purpose was the most useful and the
most arduous to vindicate the ways of
God to man. And I'll continue.
Uh, it continues, uh,
uh, I'll finish the sentence to show
the reasonableness of religion and the
necessity of obedience to the divine law.
I'll read it one more time.
His purpose was the most useful and the
most arduous to vindicate the ways of
God to man,
to show the reasonableness of religion
and the necessity of obedience to the
divine law. And, and, and,
and Johnson here is clearly thinking
of Milton's ambition of producing a
theodicy and attempt to justify
the ways of God to men. And he's,
I think he's right to identify Milton's
theodicy is really one of the central
tasks of the,
of the poem.
Milton's seems genuinely
sincere in wanting to provide
a rational and reasonable
account of the ways of God.
But you've,
you've probably noticed that
Johnson Johnson's gotten
his quotation wrong and he
may have gotten his
quotation wrong. I, uh,
because he's not thinking
directly of the Milton,
but he's thinking of Alexander Pope's
earlier thinking of the Milton from at
Pope's. Great Poem. The Essay on man,
um, pope gets it wrong as well. Uh,
Milton,
of course,
it doesn't end the opening in vocation
to book one of Paradise lost with the
claim that he will assert a providence
and vindicate the ways of God to men.
Milton says that he will
justify the ways of God to man.
And I think there's a slight,
but nonetheless,
there's a difference between these
two words and I think there's instruct
something instructive here about Johnson
slip and perhaps something instructive
to about Alexander Pope's
slip, uh, a few decades before.
Now when Milton says that
he'll justify God's ways.
I think we mean he means simply that he
will account for the justice of God's
ways. He will demonstrate
their justify ability but to,
but to vindicate God's ways.
Vindicate is a slightly different words,
although they could certainly be seen
as synonyms to vindicate God's ways.
This I would imagine to presuppose
at the outset that God is under some
suspicion of guilt,
that he's assumed to have done
something wrong and that it's our job to
vindicate him or to get him off
the hook. Milton, of course,
can't himself and doesn't. Right,
and they use the word vindicated.
It's too prejudicial.
It seems on some level to criminalize
God's behavior in advance,
and this is of course exactly
what he does not want to do.
That said,
it's on some level,
it's impossible for us to read paradise
lost and not assume that this God
requires vindication.
God seems in so many ways
to be responsible for the
fall and it might even be
impossible to read the story of
the fall in, in genesis and and,
and not attribute some of the guilt
to the yard way. Who, who put,
who placed the forbidden fruit
in the garden in the first place.
Dr. Johnson inadvertently here reveals
something about Milton's poem that Milton
himself perhaps isn't,
isn't willing,
willing or able to admit that.
And that's the God appears to be guilty
and it's up to Milton to clear him of
any suspicion of guilt.
So look at the head note that Milton
attaches to the beginning of book three.
This is page two 57 in the Hughes.
And when,
when paradise lost initially appeared
when its original appearance in 1667,
um, these arguments, these
head notes were weren't there,
he added them to a later printing,
presumably at the request of,
of a printer who thought that the
readers needed a little help with a poem.
And you actually may want to think
about, it's a, this is an interesting,
it's an interesting phenomenon
and very little written about the,
the general relation between
these summarized arguments.
They're essentially plot
summaries, um, to the actual story,
the actual narrative that
follows in each book.
But the beginning of this argument strikes
me as an especially interesting one.
So this is Milton's
argument for book three.
God sitting on his Throne Sees
Satan flying towards this world.
Then newly created shows him to the son
who Saturdays right hand foretells the
success of Satan and perverting mankind
clears his own justice and wisdom from
all imputation having created man free
and able enough to have withstood the
tempter.
I'm just going to focus on,
on on a couple of those clauses foretells
the say the success of Satan and
perverting mankind.
Then we get Milton's semi-colon clears
his own justice and wisdom from all
imputation. You, you, you, you,
you kind of get the feeling here at
least I get the feeling here that this
semi-colon is working as hard as it
possibly can to yoke these can seemingly
conflicting principles
together. And I'm not, I,
I'm not sure it's the case that any
semi-colon is, is up to such an enormous,
uh, theological task.
Uh, in this formulation,
Milton seems to own up on some level
to Johnson's characterization of the
theodicy of paradise
lost as a vindication.
God needs to clear his own justice.
He needs to clear his name in essence,
because that name has been
clouded over with some kind of,
with some kind of suspicion. Now, and I,
I take this absolutely seriously,
that, uh, I think it's,
it's with, it has to be seen
as authentic and sincere.
Milton's desire to justify God.
He needs to imagine a god who can't be
held responsible for the fall because
only a blameless God could be worthy of
Milton's praise or even more worthy of
Milton's interest. And I
think, I mean, frankly,
I think that Milton does a
pretty decent job of, uh,
of representing a god who cannot be seen
as some kind of guilty coconspirator in
the fall of man. He does a pretty
decent job vindicating God.
But then when we think about it,
there are few poets more adept at the
art of vindication than John Milton.
Milton had been practicing the art of
indication that the art of defense,
something like the art of criminal
defense all of his life. Uh,
we looked last time at the lengths to
which Milton went in is on Monday the
lakes too, when she went in
his poetry. And His prose to,
to vindicate himself with regard
to his blindness. But long before,
even long before that,
before Milton site had been cut off a
long before his Tinder or observe vision
had been quenched to use
his, uh, his, his poetry, uh,
Milton had been exercising his talents
in the rhetorical art of self defense in
Sonnet seven. And actually throughout
the earlier, throughout the early works,
Milton was defending
himself against that fear.
You remember that fear that God would
punish him for waiting so long to begin
his career that God was angry with Milton.
Milton was already 23 years old and
he had so little to show himself.
And later Milton devoted a good
deal of energy to other kinds,
other kinds of defense.
He labored to vindicate the Radical
Puritan Left in England when it was held
that they had committed a
crime in killing the king,
raising a hand against God's
anointed monarch and Europe.
Europe was aghast at the barbaric
behavior of the English revolutionaries.
And so Milton wrote in
Latin for the benefit of the
entire European intellectual
community,
two defenses of the crime of the regicide.
Um,
so he wrote a first defense of the
English people and then a work entitled a
second defense of the English people.
And there is no,
there's no question that he would have
been capable had there been time or had
there been an interest of writing a
third defense and a and a and a fourth
defense.
The Labor of defense,
the work of vindication was something
that Milton was getting very good at and
it really goes to the,
the core of his intellectual temperament.
Now, melting lays the groundwork for
his sweeping vindication of God in the
discussion in book three,
uh,
between the heavenly father and his son.
And this is essentially the same theology
that Milton will establish in the
theological treatise that he's riding.
At the same time that he's writing
paradise lost, um, on Christian doctrine,
parts of which were assigned,
uh, for today's class.
Now it's important for Milton
to establish something like,
and this is what he gets to do in the,
in the venue of the prose treatise
as opposed to the poem. He,
he has the opportunity to establish
a theoretical basis for a lot of his
beliefs. And so a theoretical
basis for his vindication of God.
He needs to prove theologically,
not just poetically or narratively,
that God did not place Adam and eve in
the garden with the intent or with the,
the purpose in mind of punishing them
for eating the fruit he needs to convince
himself in.
It needs to convince his reader.
Milton does that the fact of God's fore
knowledge of the fall doesn't in any way
cause the fall. And this is a huge
worry not just for Milton but,
but for all philosophically minded,
philosophically minded Christians that,
that the faculty have freewill
is that as a genuine faculty,
this is something that in Milton really
needs to believe and that it's not just
some paper McShea con concept pasted
together by a cynical and manipulative
deity or by a cynical
and manipulative poet.
Okay.
And in order to assert this belief in a
genuinely meaningful faculty of freewill
mean Milton has to tackle head on
the theology of his fellow puritans.
The prevailing theology
of his, of his, uh,
of his fellow puritans Milton has to
dismantle. And this is no easy task,
dismantle the Calvinist doctrine
of, of, of divine predestination.
Now,
the most prevalent,
the most prevalent belief among Milton's
contemporary puritans was the belief,
this belief in divine
predestination and nearly all,
all the men and women that we can identify
comfortably as puritans embrace the
faith in God's omnipotence outlined
in the works of John Calvin, uh,
Calvin being the 16th
century Swiss theologian,
actually French theologian
living in Geneva,
who insisted that every one's salvation
could be traced back ultimately to the
predestined will of God.
And so for Calvin,
God is not only known since the
beginning of time, what we will do,
but God actually causes us in
some sense to do what we do.
There's very little
space for a meaningful,
a range of free will in a,
in a strict Calvinist system.
And it's God then who is,
who has for Calvin elected in advance,
who will be saved and who will be damned
and, and Calvin was, was, was justified,
or at least he felt he was justified
and many of his followers felt he was
justified in this assertion
of God's control. Um,
when he read the passage from
Saint Paul's epistle to the Romans,
and this is the, this is the
passage for whom I'll, uh,
let me read the whole thing.
This is Romans eight 29
for whom he did for no,
he also did predestinate to be conformed
to the image of his son. Moreover,
whom he did predestinate them.
He also called and whom he called them.
He also justified and whom he
justified them. He also glorified
for whom he did for no, he also did
predestinate. It's a devastating,
it's a perfectly devastating Bible
buffers for anyone committed to a strong
stance as Milton wise on the,
in the doctrine of free. Well.
So on some level,
at least in this passage from Saint Paul,
Romans eight 29 scriptures seemed to
provide in controvertible evidence for the
fact that God had already
predestined the elect.
Those Christians who had arbitrarily at
the very foundation of time been elected
for our salvation.
And that by extension God had also,
and this is another important component
of the Calvinists theological system,
that God had also arbitrarily marked
another group of men and women for
punishment and eternal damnation
seems in controvertible.
But we're, we're, this is,
this course is about Milton.
And of course nothing is in
controvertible for Milton.
And you see him tangled
with just this passage,
this passage from the book of
Romans for two solid pages in,
in on Christian doctrine.
And,
and you just have a sense that Milton is
saying this can't possibly mean what it
seems to me.
And there's a,
there's a genuine and powerful
urgency charging Milton's,
it's like a wrestling match almost with a,
with a,
with a biblical passage like this.
And so one of the important conclusions
that Milton comes to in his wrestling
match trust scripture is that the term
elect as Saint Paul uses it in the Bible,
doesn't refer to God's absolute
predestination. And actually,
let me, um, let me ask you to
turn to page in your Hughes.
This is page nine, 21, uh,
uh, of the Christian doctrine.
Knowlton writes that
I infer I conclude that believers are
the same as the elect and that the terms
are used indiscriminately.
I'm going to read that again.
I conclude that believers are the same
as the elect and that the terms are used
indiscriminately.
Believers are the elect.
And because of course we
get to choose on some level,
we get to choose whether or not we
believe. We therefore get to choose.
We have some agency in whether or not
we are going to be one of God's elect.
This is wonder,
one of Milton's most compelling and
really wonderful perversions of,
of mainstream Calvinist theology.
Uh,
Calvin had insisted on predestination
to assert God's absolute control over or
over his creation and God's absolute
control over that set final separation.
At the end of time between the saved
and the damned Calvin felt that that,
that the, his theology was
the least we could, uh,
there's the least we owed to the gray,
the grand juror and
the omnipotence of God.
But from Milton to say that believers
are the same as the elect is essentially,
I think on some level to
strip god of that control.
If this is Milton,
we're defending something like a
usurpation of Gods of God's authority,
and it's the same strategy that you will
see Milton employing a time and again,
he's able to,
and it's the damnedest thing.
He's able to take the most depressingly
constrictive biblical doctrine and he
turns it into a proof.
He turns it into a proof for his own
faith and man's absolutely freewill.
And Milton's philosophy of he's
not the only person doing this,
but he does it with more ingenuity
perhaps than just about any of his
contemporaries.
Milton's philosophy of freewill is often
called Arminianism and a Arminianism is
named after the 16th century
Dutch theologian James.
Our mini as,
I don't,
I can't remember the Dutch name off the
top of my head had Jacobus Arminius is
the, is the Latin name that
he published under. Now,
I've been speaking of the theology
of freewill as if it were,
if I as if it were simply a matter of,
of religious doctrine or exclusively
a matter of religious doctrine.
And of course, probably more
importantly than any than any other way,
it is a matter of religious doctrine,
but religion,
and I think this can be
said not just for Milton,
it surely it can be said for all of us.
Religion serves a whole
range of cultural functions.
We saw last time some of the deeply
personal uses to which Milton was able to
put his theology just as he needs to,
just as he needs to prove that God's
omniscience and omnipotence is not a sign
of, of his responsibility for the fall.
Milton needed to prove that his blindness,
his blindness wasn't a sign of
God's punishment of, of Milton.
That was a personal motivation for some
of the theological energies of Milton's
poem. But I think more
central to Milton's theology,
uh, than anything like a personal
motivation is Milton's politics.
Although the political sphere is,
is intimately intertwined with anything
that we would want to think of is as
personal theology and,
and political philosophy.
These obviously seem to us such
radically distinct spheres of thought.
Um, but they're incredibly closely
intertwined in the 17th century.
And I think there are all sorts of all
sorts of political and social motivations
for Milton's theology.
There are political and social reasons
for the fact that some of the periods
radical intellectuals like Milton are
beginning to assert radically to assert
the importance of man's freewill and
beginning at the same time to diminish the
authority that had traditionally in the
Calvinist system been accorded to God.
And I think there's a
political significance to the,
the periods renewed renewed attachment
to and investment in the philosophy or
the theology of Arminius who,
as you can see,
he had died at the very beginning
of the 17th century. Um,
Arminianism has a new way,
maybe it's third wave by the later,
the later part of the, of the 17th
century. Now, as we know from the, the,
the treatise area politica and from
Milton's regicide a writings as well,
Milton was establishing himself in the
middle part of the century as one of
England's foremost,
one of the England's most articulate
spokesman for a phenomenon that we can
call. Although it's an [inaudible],
it's an anachronistic term liberalism.
And so obviously the word liberalism
hasn't, hasn't emerged yet,
but you have something like
a theory of liberalism,
or at least a theory of libertarianism,
a beginning to assert itself in
the middle of the 17th century.
You have a serious formulation of,
of liberalism later in the 17th century,
shortly after Milton dies,
um, with the philosopher John Locke,
who was a great reader of Milton.
I'm traditional renaissance
political thought was before lock.
And I think you can say before Milton
was more or less authoritarian,
it placed a monarch at the top of the
society at the top of the polity and
traditional renaissance political
thought needed to imagine that monarchs
control.
Um,
his ultimate governance over the
behavior and the actions of all of the
individuals in that society,
that this political philosophy
in variably asserted the,
the importance of a radical
image of centralization of power.
And it's really not until the middle
of the 17th century that Europeans,
and it's not just not just Englishman
or beginning to articulate any serious
alternative to the authoritarian,
the centralized model of,
of political organization. There are
people on the, on the radical left and,
and Milton is one of them,
um,
who begin to posit the idea that the
dispersed individuals throughout our
society can be reasonably depended on,
to govern themselves with, with
sufficient self control. Of course,
such a theory assumes a lot of things.
It assumes a sufficient degree of self
control that every individual would have.
Um,
with this self controlled rational
individuals could organize themselves with
that without a king,
without the top down.
A hierarchical structure of,
of a monarchy and the, and the, the, this,
this position most is most
often associated in England,
at least in the middle of the
century with the levelers. Um,
the levelers are the intellectual,
the highminded intellectual
component of the,
of the army of during the English
revolution during the middle of the 17th
century. Um, and uh, the, the,
the level or theory of sovereignty is
something like an intellect and elected
sovereignty.
If there's a sovereign,
that sovereign will be elected or
chosen by the people and it won't be the
sovereign not going to be
imposed upon the people. Um,
and so it'll election in a lot of ways.
It's not simply a theological Turnitin,
obviously to, to this day it has
political resonances as well.
So this brand new liberal,
what I'm calling a liberal theology
is not only political in nature,
however, it's also, it's also economic.
It's at precisely the same period,
the mid 17th century when something like,
yeah,
again,
I'll use the term anachronistically when
something like a liberal market theory
of economic exchange as being theorized.
So up until, so I'll give you a little,
a brief history of, of the,
the, the of economic thought.
In the early modern period.
Up until this point,
it was assumed that the only efficient
way to organize the economic life of a
nation was to have the monarch,
the sovereign,
the authoritarian center of the
government, fixed prices and a to and to,
to determine the value
of currency in general,
to oversee the dynamics of just
about all economic exchange.
But suddenly,
and this really is happening in the 1650
and it's happening first in England,
suddenly a liberal economic theory
is coming into view and it was being
conjectured that individuals,
meaning individual merchants could freely
set prices and values according to the
law of supply and demand rather than
according to the law of the authority,
the authoritarian will of the king.
And there's a wonderful book on
this subject by Joyce Appleby.
If any of you are interested, um, it's,
I can't remember what it's called,
but you'll figure it out from orbis.
Which of joy's Apple Bee's
wonderful books. This is a,
but the argument is essentially that a
free market philosophy had simply been
unthinkable. The free market
philosophy that we just take as a,
as a given almost was unthinkable before
the middle years of the 17th century.
And so you have these two enormous shifts
in the way that English intellectuals
were thinking about their political
and also about their economic lives.
And it seems to me that it only stands
to reason that there's going to be a
corresponding shift or some site sort of
related shift on the level of religious
thought. If individuals are going to be
liberated from their earthly monarch,
if merchants are going to be liberated
from the centralizing power of the,
of the sovereign in charge of the economy,
then individual souls are going to have
to be liberated at least to some extent
from the predestined very stronghold
of the heavenly monarch as well as if,
um,
intellectual life could operate in these
huge analogous in these with these huge
analogous forms.
And I think that that's one of the
functions of Milton's insistence on the,
his liberal,
his liberal theology of freewill.
It's as if he needs to bring
his religion in line with his,
with his liberal politics.
So now let's look at the
dialog and heaven. Um,
okay,
turn to page
260 in the Hughes. This
is book three, line 93.
Uh,
it's,
it's hearing the dialogue
and having between the father
and the son were so many
of the tensions between Calvin is
predestination and miltonic freewill get,
get worked out. Um, but let,
let me digress for a moment before
we actually look at the dialogue.
I think it's important to ask why it is.
And I think people have been asking this
question since people have been reading
paradise lost.
Why it is that God,
the father and God the son needed to
be holding a dialogue at all? What,
what is it that they need
to say to one another? Um,
I think we can reasonably ask,
ask for Orthodox Christians
in Milton's time.
And I think for a lot of Orthodox
Christians in, in our time,
the father and the son,
or members of what's known as the trinity,
the father,
the son and the Holy
Spirit are paradoxically
according to most trinitarian
thinking,
are paradoxically three separate entities.
But they are also most importantly,
one unified entity.
And because they are all
one and all equally one,
it borders almost on blast for me to
imagine the father and the son needing to
discuss anything. But,
but Milton realized that,
and this is uh, this was, uh,
an extraordinary and bold
move on his part. Milton, uh,
argued that there was no basis in
scripture for a belief in the trinity.
And people had always known that the
word trinity actually appears nowhere in
the scripture. And you can see
Milton in the Christian doctrine,
uh,
supplying mountains,
literally mountains of
evidence of scriptural evidence
to disprove the doctrine
of the Christian,
the Christian doctrine of the trinity.
So Milton took very seriously the
biblical metaphors of father and son.
The father and the son are, are not mere,
they're not aspects of the same deity.
They are literally for Milton,
a father and a son.
And when the God refers in Scripture
to my only begotten Son or to my first
begotten son, he really means
it. According to Milton,
the father generates the son.
Uh,
he gives birth to him at a
specific moment in, in, uh, in,
in pre creation history.
And Milton is therefore we can call him
or he has been called a subordination
hissed. He subordinates the son to the
father because the sun will never be,
or at least not until the very end of
time, will never be the fathers equal.
Okay.
And, and so the sun can
in no way be imagined, um,
okay.
Identical or equal to the father
and the father can, when he chooses,
and this happens in paradise lost,
he can grant a certain measure
of power to the sun, but the sun,
no in no way,
possesses a this,
the same in any kind of power that
hasn't been granted to him at God's,
at God's pleasure or, or the, the, the,
he and the sun has nothing like the
fore knowledge or omnipotence that the
father has.
Now we see this undoing things,
performing actions in paradise lost,
for example,
he's responsible for having created or
serving as the vehicle for the creation
of the entire known universe.
Not, not negligible perhaps,
but he, he can only perform
these godlike feats. And he goes,
can they only be called God?
Like not actually God,
when the father permits
him to perform such feats,
he needs his father's permission.
And like Adam and eve,
it's beholden upon the to obey the father.
This is,
this is crucial to Milton's theology.
So look at how all these,
this,
these domestic essentially domestic
relations get theologized in the dialogue
and heaven,
um,
line 93 of book three
and the father of course,
and it just drives me crazy.
The father speaks in the future tense of
absolute for knowledge because he can,
and, and, and, and you're right to think,
I hope you've thought
that there's something,
a little chilling about the fathers
discursive manner here. Um, the,
the way in which he can shift so easily
between the past tense and the future
tense.
So the line 93,
this is the Father Furman will hearken
to Satan's closing lies and easily
transgressed the sole command
sold pledge of his obedience.
So we'll fall. He and his
faithfulness progeny, whose fault,
whose but his own
in great.
Ouch.
Whose fault,
whose but his own in great.
He had of me all he could have.
I made him Justin,
right sufficient to have stood though
free to fall such I created all the,
the ethereal powers and spirits,
both them who stood and them
who failed freely. They stood,
who stood and fell,
who fell.
Now I'm going to set aside here
because I can't deal with it. Um, this,
this little outbursts that
seems so incredibly in
decorous and inappropriate in
great. Um, and uh, I'm,
I'm going to discuss instead the
last line that I just read, uh,
which is indicates,
indicates I think one of the central
rhetorical strategies of the father's
speech. Now look at line 99. First.
There's something literally liberating
about the father's credo here.
I created man, sufficient to
have stood though free to fall.
This is, this is kind of rousing
and as rousing as this is,
the father doesn't leave it there.
He broaches the subject of
the fallen angels and he
repeats the same formulation,
but he repeats it with the difference.
Look at line 101
he has just,
he's just discussed both of them who
stood and them who failed freely.
They stood, who stood and fell, who
fell freely. They still do stood, fell,
who fell. The father recasts that,
that original statement within a,
within a repetitive rhetoric,
it's essentially a repetitive
rhetoric of totology.
And in so doing,
I think he exposes something of
the highly schematic nature of,
of his sense of justice. And, and,
and this last line is often
cited and Milton criticism as a,
as a positive example of Milton's
commitment to the doctrine of free will.
But I don't,
I don't really buy it though.
I'm not convinced by the fathers,
the fathers statement,
this line may begin with that
exuberant an adverb freely,
but the rest of it,
at least to me,
the rest of it smacks of something
like predestination and it's a little
depressing. They stood who
stood and fell, who fell?
Is it a stretch to
extrapolate from that? Um, uh,
a paraphrase like this,
the type of person who was created to
stand didn't stand and the type of person
who was created to fall did fall.
There's something disconcertingly
programmatic about the father's repetition
here. The repetitiveness
of his explanation and the
tautological force of this
formulation seems to rob the
opening word in the line,
freely robs it of some of
its liberatory energy. Okay.
That was the father speech
wonderfully.
The Sun seems almost to recoil from the,
from the rigidity of the father's
position and in fact he seems actually to
soften the father a little. He asked
the father to show mercy toward man,
since man like the son himself is,
is a son of God and it's at this point
you get the the fathers and you want to,
you want to throttle him.
The father's condescending claim that
of course he knew all along that the sun
would be asking for mercy and Milton is
obliged to make the father omission of
course,
because the father is omniscient.
Although the entire drama of this
dialogue is structured as any drama or any
dialogue has to be structured to suggest
that there are two individuals who are
reacting genuinely to one another speeches
because they don't know in advance
what the other is going to
say. That's what a dialogue,
that's what a dialogue is.
But there's clearly a powerful
asymmetry here in this dialogue.
Um, and that the asymmetry
threatens, I think too,
to cast this entire scene
into some something like, uh,
uh,
a potentially ridiculous light,
but the sun does seem,
at least he does seem to have made a kind
of impact on the father and the father
seems to relent and,
and the father agrees to accept
the repentance of Adam and eve.
So look at line one 94.
This is at the top of page two 63.
The father promises to show mercy and he
promises to permit Adam and eve a safe
journey back into his good graces.
So line one 94 and I will place them,
I will place within them as a guide my
umpire conscience whom if they will hear
light after light, well
used, they shall attain.
And to the end persisting safe arrive.
It's as if the father has
been cajoled by the sun,
cajoled out of his repetitive cyclicality
and nudge towards something like a
more linear and to my tastes
are more palatable form of,
of human progress.
And I think we sigh with relief at
the knowledge that all will be well.
All will be well. Again, after the fall
we have all of the earmarks here of a,
of a narrative.
I'm moving from a,
from a a beginning through a middle,
toward an end.
Then we sigh with relief at
the knowledge that all that,
that everything is going to be okay. But
of course this relief is only momentary.
As soon as the father has
agreed to this concession,
as soon as he's promised
they're safe journey
back to God,
he adds a condition.
And this condition appears at line 203.
This is near the top of page two 63.
Um,
he returns to that rhetoric of repetition
and equivalents that had marked his
earlier speech,
but yet all is not done.
What had led us to
well used, they shall attain unto the
end, persisting, safe, safe arrive.
It did seem that pretty
much all was all was done,
but there's some backtracking here, but
yet all is not done. Man. Disobeying,
disloyal breaks his field team and sins
against the high supremacy of heaven
effecting godhead.
And so losing all to expiate his treason
hath not left but to destruction,
sacred and devote he with
his whole posterity must die,
die.
He or justice must
unless for him some other able and as
willing paid the rigid satisfaction,
death for death,
but yet all is not done.
You can almost hear Milton in
this line catching himself and,
and realizing that man,
of course wasn't redeemed simply because
Adam and eve were repentance simply
because they said they were sorry.
It has the scene force is that incredibly
startling moment in the naitivity owed
when Milton tells us. But why is this?
Fate says no, this must not yet be. So,
uh,
Milton just can't get away.
Although he certainly gives it a shot.
He can't get away from the unhappy fact
that man was not redeemed simply because
Adam and Eve said they were sorry man
was redeemed through the much more
troubling for Milton,
the troubling mechanism of the
father's sacrifice of the son.
And Milton has successfully avoided
finishing his poem about the crucifixion,
The Passion, the poem called the
passion when he was a young man,
it just went unfinished.
And as you read the dialogue in
Heaven in Book Three of Paradise lost,
it seems for a while at least it seems
that Milton is going to be able to evade
the entire question of the
sacrifice one more time. But, but,
but he catches himself,
but yet all is not done.
And he forces consideration of,
of the atonement of the crucifixion.
And it's crucial to understanding
exactly how it is that Milton here is
imagining the dynamics of the redemption.
So Milton,
first of all,
it has to reject the
Orthodox understanding of the
Christian redemption. Um,
I'll, I'll, uh, I'll,
I'll remind you what that looks like
in the New Testament and for a lot of
Christian theologians,
the redemption seems to work along
the lines of something like a revenge
sacrifice and Q and as cultural
anthropologists have taught us,
there's something like a primitive logic,
uh,
an intensely primitive logic at work
behind the notion of the Christian notion
of the crucifixion. One of the
Fathers Sons Adam, has died.
And so the father will avenge that
death by murdering someone else.
And of course that means
murdering another son.
And Th th this model of redemption is
based on the repetition or a repetition of
the initial crime.
And this logic of repetition I think is
largely responsible for that rhetoric of
repetitiveness that, that we hear
so often in the father's speech.
And so according to this,
we can think of it as a sacrifice theory
of redemption or of the atonement God
chooses to sacrifice his son.
Since someone is going to have
to be punished for Adam's sin.
That's the logic demands that,
but Milton I think can imagine
no aspect of his religion,
no aspect of Christianity,
more barbaric than the image of the
father's willing sacrifice of his son.
Th th this would be a god truly
unworthy of Milton's justification.
And Milton struggling here,
and there are a few of his contemporaries
are doing the same thing in the 17th
century, he struggling to
bring Christianity in line
with certain standards of
rationality. And as Dr. Johnson
had said in the, in the,
in the rest of the sentence
that I wrote on the board,
Milton wants to show the
reasonableness of religion.
And so Milton replaces the sacrifice model
of the redemption with something like
a satisfaction model of redemption.
According to this, according to
this way of thinking in Adam's sin,
a debt has been incurred and this debt
can be satisfied by someone else's
payment. So revenge is no
longer the motive. It's,
it's something like an economic desire
simply to balance the books. It,
there's something impersonal about this
new way of imagining the atonement.
And it's here that Milton gives the
notion of the Christian redemption. It's,
it's particular miltonic twist.
Milton's father does not
willingly sacrifice the son. He,
it's, it's magnificent. He
simply asks for a volunteer and,
and the son out of his
goodness volunteers,
he chooses to make
himself mortal. And, and,
and it's a perfect example.
Have I have a foul?
Milton has shifted the emphasis away
from Christian Orthodoxy and, and,
and forcing the authoritarian image of
God's sacrifice to yield to Milton's
liberal image of a kind of volunteerism
or libertarian image of volunteerism.
The son chooses to humiliate himself and
subsequently God chooses to compensate
that humiliation with the
Sun Supreme Exaltation.
And you see the extent of
this compensation at line
three 11 and book three,
page two 65, uh, near the bottom
of the page, God says to the son,
because in the Love Hath
abounded more than glory abounds.
Therefore the humiliation shall exalt
with the dye manhood also to this throne.
Here shelt sit here shalt,
I'll sit incarnate here.
Shelt rain. Both God and Man,
son, both of God and man anointed,
universal king, all power. I give the
reign forever and assume
the merits under the,
as head supreme Thrones.
Princeton's powers dominions,
I reduce to reward the son for having
sacrificed himself for having sacrificed
himself. The father is going
to give the son all power and,
and this complete,
it seems like it's going to come be
a complete transference of power and,
and it's a transfer that will
hold until at the end of time.
There will no longer even be a difference
presumably between the father and the
son because as the father says at
line three 41 God shall be all in all,
there will be no power differential
whatsoever between the father and the son.
And presumably they'll note be no power
differential between or among any of us.
Um,
we're will all be joined at the
end of time and one massive liberal
nonhierarchical state of heart harmony.
And the image of the all in all is, is,
is Milton's most exuberant
visionary endpoint.
And it satisfies,
I think a lot of Milton's most liberal
impulses and even the authoritarian
instruction structure of heaven.
And of course Milton's heaven
is as a is as authoritarian as,
as any heaven has ever been conceived.
Um,
even it will be transformed into
something like a fantasy of,
of egalitarianism,
a fantasy of absolute equality.
And this ecstatic redistribution of power
and glory at the end of time can only
come about because the sun has
so willingly humiliated himself.
He subjects himself to the
father's wrath. No, and I think we,
I think we recognize this gesture,
this image of the noble and voluntary
self sacrifice. This is the matter.
This is the,
this is the image that
Milton had established in his
defenses of his blindness.
Milton had written in the Sonnet
that we looked down on Monday,
meant to Mr Syriac Skinner.
And he had also written in the second
defense of the English people that he had
willingly sacrificed his site for
the good of his fellow Englishman.
He lost his eyes over,
applied in Liberty's defense,
my noble task Milton had
written in that sonnet.
And in the second defense,
Milton explains that he continued to
write his regicide treatises despite the
advice of his doctors who insisted
that he would go blind if he continued.
That's how important the project
was for Milton and the sacrifice.
And you'll begin to see a way in which
the two dominant features of book three,
uh,
Milton's invocation to light and the
discussion of blindness they're in and the
dialogue between the father and
the son, that, that they're,
they're speaking to one another and
they're, they're functioning in, in a,
in a kind of parallel fashion.
So just as the sun's voluntary sacrifice
will rewarded with his inheritance on
some level,
the,
the heavenly plot of Paradise lost is
essentially an inheritance narrative.
Um, the sun's voluntary sacrifice will be
rewarded with his inheritance of all of
God's power,
um,
presumably to Milton sacrificed.
We'll also be rewarded by God.
It's as if Milton wants the
same compensation of paternal
power that the son had
been granted for undergoing his sacrifice.
Look, look at, let me see.
What do I have time for
the,
the transfusion of divine power.
That Milton imagines the transfer
of power from father to the son if
extrapolated to the situation
of the poet and his God would,
would guarantee the inspired
success of the poem.
And what would that mean?
It would guarantee essentially
the status of paradise lost.
As as scripture itself as
something divinely authorized
or perhaps even divinely
authored.
That at least is is its relation to
Milton's personal concern with his own
composition of, of paradise
lost. But, but this,
this image of a kind of divine,
divine transfusion of power
and an ultimate transference
of power also I think
speaks to the political component
of Milton's theology. You,
you having this passage,
an image of a transfer of power from a,
from a centralized authority,
the creator of the entire universe
to the humble individual, the,
the image supplies,
essentially the conceptual
foundation for Milton's liberalism,
that form of social organization whereby
power has been shifted away from the
center, away from the monarch
and toward the subject.
And you will find images of,
of inheritance and of transference.
And if transfusion abounding in,
in paradise lost and they,
and they crop up in all sorts of venues,
often having nothing whatsoever to do,
um, with the, with the interact,
the domestic interactions
of the, of the godhead.
And these images prepare us for that
beautiful but truly outrageous endpoint of
Christian history that Milton foresees
the point at which God, the, the,
the one that God had foretold in his
speech to the sun. There will be a point,
there will come a point in time
in which God shall be all in all.
And that's an idea that works on
the level of theology to satisfy,
uh, nearly every desire to satisfy, uh,
the personal,
the social and the political
desires of what we can,
I think,
not entirely wrongly.
Think of as Milton's idea
of the liberal Christian.
Okay, I'm going to end there. And uh,
we will all read very closely book for,
for Wednesday's class.